worse of fool podcast
[Music]
Rena dress
[ __ ] what you heard slaughter is back
people they've been training for two
years now training training and they've
been getting outfits they're gonna [ __ ]
about our tour bus before get actual
tour they had a [ __ ] band with all
the equipment I don't think I got a
drummer they got a two guitarist they
got a female guitarist
they got Martina I wouldn't even say
lead vocals just vocals and Mara know
what they're doing up there man but they
got a famine up to their shows their
first albums because slaughter before
slaughter the band that I really wanted
to be good it was like the [ __ ] with
the devil horns the only light I know
masked by the first time I saw one I
just I heard you know the song no I just
heard the ones that were posted on a
slaughter before slaughters Instagram
page so about Dean and who I was doing
it I know Tanya Estrada is in the band
from what I seen the band with them if
not with the black women or the black
dude that plays a mayor and back to the
future
when at the diner the guy who's sweeping
the floor and he's a black guy sweeping
the floor and then later he becomes the
mayor in the future
folk yeah my jewel time music hey Emma
do we have the video what's up fool
what's our full podcast what's up people
man
oh man I'm already having an awesome
math week man I was in a movie yesterday
yeah I worked on a movie yesterday with
the Phantom with the Phantom with forget
about Billy Zane Alizee yeah Bassmaster
Bassmaster and changed his name to bass
most that's his name right now it's his
last name know there's like Nikki Sixx
in huh it was like before Rodriguez I'll
do that for Z their Italian or some type
of plantain dog plan teens are like you
know they go southern Guatemala El
Salvador Chile yeah it's cuz Vinny's mom
Porto Rican so every time we would see a
Puerto Rican beuter Cuba do well there's
a plan teen because I know we would say
that laughing in [ __ ] every time she
would make a stake in black knows we're
saying plantain no but it's plantain but
we know we would say plantain on the
side in the back laughing
make us some plantains and she'll go yes
yeah but III know what wasn't or Tia's
even thought everybody wanted her over
Spanish my real name is Damian in the
city you had to fight to stay alive yeah
it was cool seeing your niece at the
Spanish show last night because I said
you understand this that's cool man cuz
I know she doesn't really speak it but
she understands that of course she was
raised by her grandma
well he'll be what shut out two or three
October for beaver loss chieftains
aminah art stand a Riverside like
Ferguson yeah it was a fifteen dollar
short to get in man if you got missed
out should've been there
Danny Franny was there any Frank and his
twin who lived in Eagle Rock Victor Lily
brothers often that brother bro like
slamming Jim one of those brothers are
brothers in wrestling the bushwhackers a
bush way look at the clean version of
those fools yeah late 80s early 90s the
kippur kids and their big chins and they
were like they weren't bushwhackers it
was for kids it was some I think was a
British they were weird looking guys
with real long chins their prosthetic
chins on their faces Swedish I remember
that one okay you have fun on stage
ville yeah man but they're well helped
me was that up I've been doing now I've
been like I've been doing the same set
in the same way and not changing it so
when I went up on stage I didn't
remember how to do it I just did it in
Spanish oh wow no I remember them but I
[ __ ] Brody Stevens I'm back wow it
was a good set dude it was a really
really [ __ ] good you know I was
[ __ ] really tripping on how people
were responding to me I was going like
these fools gonna correct us or they
gonna but dude it [ __ ] flowed like
gravity dog was tight the [ __ ] the
Cookie Monster killed it for those guys
were wrestlers no they just I don't know
what they were per second it was like a
duo like a nut car yes that's wispy
comedy was not funny had more chin in
Asia I never watched them like that I
watch them once and I just didn't get it
and so I'd never watched their show like
any coffee go to Showtime or HBO or
something like that
let the flight of the conchords before
their time possibly yemen
was so full what's a full shout out to
everybody they came out to our show in
Charlotte North Carolina so many people
showed up from City Terrace is Los
Angeles and Pomona representing
relocated to the South awful yeah man I
remember for 80 good food yeah yeah lady
go goes Yvette Yvette sure ought to let
it go go she brought some [ __ ] bomb
ass big issue letter told us more Charta
that she was [ __ ] bomb and then we
still haven't she loud that was her
didn't taste how are they then July was
good they're even good cold I hate them
in the mine damn and the carne asada and
the jackfruit chocolate were bomb we
also made a comedian after who lives in
a van some comedian name of Elvis moose
novice moose or mooch which that food
from Bosnia and originally from Detroit
Bosnian comedian he came up to do it or
five minutes kill that [ __ ] so this fool
maybe I'm gonna look I'm up his name is
I'm Elvis Moyes which is bestowed Mui CH
I think Elvis moist and if you got like
dark comedy like real dark comedy this
is your guy you know for a quick five
minutes is he like Jason rouse type not
is uh that is hard cool yeah yeah but
you can definitely get dog but this guy
bad he said kind of like a hamburger
yeah yeah so this guy walks into a let's
go this cat was here to a Waffle House
so he walks into a Waffle House right
and he talked to the people there at the
manager and he was a my name is Elvis
moosh I'm a comedian from Bosnia
there it is Moyes was just mu G I see
yeah mu G I see with the Nexen okay I
see Elvis
mu GIC right j IC mu j IC with music
yeah and we found him on instagram @ @
elvis comedy
well if who walks into a copy like a
[ __ ] Waffle House and he touches a
manager there a-and he plugs in his own
boombox his own microphone and he does
stand-up comedy like at Waffle House's
like in the middle of the night and also
during the day he walks into her [ __ ]
um he walks into a homeless shelters
like homeless shelters and asked
whoever's in charge if he could go in
there and perform for the homeless
people and he also goes to Vietnam
shelters with Vietnam vets hospitals
Veterans Hospitals and wherever though
they are a VFW's and he just does that
man like nobody gives him no you know he
probably takes a little basket to pay
but anyways shut up to that fool he live
in a van he's sober yeah but on Sunday
he made a big mistake but he brought
somebody from the VFW with him he
brought a soldier kidnapped so this
would you look at the Nuge he left his
house behind first of all to live in a
band he brought this guy was an idiot
[Laughter]
that's why I don't guess what do you do
for what you do for a living he was I
used to be a bodyguard there's a
bodyguard would you protect United
States of America miss I called out I
put over to a side and I put a come here
man we tell you nothing but think ahead
cause one time let me open his mouth
through the show he is [ __ ] out of
here over here given the boot out of
here I know it's weird to be mad at
somebody know you a positive brother I
revere I know you a book of your bed
already
if you know advocacy like I said like a
civil person person or I don't give a
[ __ ] what you did man right came in like
a cowboy give me their table where's the
beer I'll put a beer
we're cut out right away like yeah
everybody took orders right all right so
when you go sit on your seat
[Laughter]
hell no charge him for everything he did
18 years of Lies to party to do a coke a
dozen protecting the [ __ ] army
he said no protecting the Marines that
was his job he was in the army and
protecting the Marines
dude he looked like somebody's [ __ ]
uncle the [ __ ] fell out of a plane
you know that's somebody that picked up
by army jackets on a trashy guy leave a
Jew because it was dark dude you're 65
your hair's not that black look at my
forty dog come on you're killing me yeah
I got two beers ain't quick and missing
like he has one of the longest teeth he
was missing a tooth the horse tooth you
are not a bodyguard
so no could get a bug that you thought
about they fun real Facebook you know
I'd like you worked for black waters of
his neighbor's toilet that's what he
said he was his name and his company he
look like a beat-up Nuge yeah man it was
just crazy [ __ ] ever use these oh
yeah [ __ ] now catcher's mitts
he's packing I can't figure was too big
to be a penetrator
this was a little Roach crawls out of
his jacket off yeah he's a good dude bro
that roll those cigarettes out exactly
yes don't put the filter he's like one
of those dudes that you play to clean up
your yard cuz you feel sorry for him and
then he never does the work now it just
takes a 24-hour job hobble propellers
you don't even know who's telling you
the truth that he a veteran a real
veteran ain't never gonna be wearing
meadows george w gave it to that letter
from Clinton bro like the one mr.
Jackson had what it [ __ ] that movie
Crazy eight yeah hey hey yeah bro I have
a big letter product yeah George Bush
himself wrote me a letter and thanked me
person for the [ __ ] letter that's a
good thing I wish there was more time
today oh my god yes wait I gotta end
this letter now I've seen mrs. Bush
calling me down I got my sandwich ready
come on Xerox his signature dog wasn't
even a [ __ ] pen I'm old enough to say
it nine purple hearts bro with your cat
fool and I really Wow press my friends
on your be sure to jorge vasquez we are
you an army [ __ ] a whole life oh my
a career [ __ ] wait to play guns that
we took all the replicas bro damn so he
was already before were to play guns
that will come over the replica 45 in
his pocket and a [ __ ] real sword like
the civil what the [ __ ] glory over here
tombstone it was a rat house and Apple
Church with a BB gun had a [ __ ] fly
all over the house dog
he made this grandma blind you oh my god
[ __ ] people
but hey you were so foolish man was it a
Spanish or crazy she's about 40 minutes
man I think by the time I filmed the
special I'll be ready bro did it look
crisp last night didn't [ __ ] I was
really surprised by the [ __ ] uh
interaction in the crowds they were
digging that [ __ ] dawg everybody's
[ __ ] proud as [ __ ] happy huh
they were like into it dawg a little I
like you little you know what II finally
somebody from here to the especially
Spain that the [ __ ] say that bad
right somebody representing arts oz
Mexican or Latinos here in America how
we grew up how we are dude it's like
dude everybody wants a [ __ ] import a
Latino dog we're already here dog not to
be addicted but and everybody in Mexico
wants to be like the u.s. anyway so it's
like what the [ __ ] dog we're already
here hahaha I'm saying [ __ ] we got
punchlines so I heard a movie bro yeah
what's the title the movie is to work in
town yes book no guess house guest house
not a guest house is in LA yeah well
that [ __ ] your house we shot it was
undisclosed location so we're in Los
Angeles bro
I forgot how we got there but dude like
there was a front house which I didn't
go inside up but the back house was
[ __ ] useful
four bedrooms back out backyard dude
okay
the front house is a manner yeah and man
it was like because there's a there's
like a big giant rectangular pool and it
was a front house and then the other
side of the pool right when you go into
the pool was the back house and they're
like a sliding door they had their own
yard in the back too damn little we feel
their dogs [ __ ] rich and fool who
live there and I was talking to the
floor sighs well thoughtful a fat
outside bro that footpath the badass
boat without leaving all right so you
looking construction bro little [ __ ]
oh boy in charge of selling Python fool
they were over there they took that foot
bandage can you like shut down though
every brother I have her up doing a god
job will here with 200 dollars click OK
without side when I'm talking to him
right now see buddy homie I heard they
give you 500 dollars to [ __ ] chill
out that [ __ ] jackhammer Charlie hold
on they gave it to me
they're fooling me inside a house that
they're building there dude they knock
down like an old beat-up
the houses that used to be the
neighborhood you to be ranch died or
like mine yeah I flag on a sleep so they
knocked them all down do another like
all like picture is take you know a very
chic fun fun too
Francois the Francois the picture or
whatever there's where everything like
with water everything matches bad
[ __ ] maybe that's two million dollar
homes how are you functioning okay Lula
Santana in 1969 he'll play the master
all right now when the next show is
badly the lake shores bandage will be
this Saturday in Sandy San Diego at the
palace comedy palace in San Diego it
should tickets tickets are 15 bucks
pretty decent right go check that out
that's funny man I don't know how about
after the speciality what's up if we're
doing more English shows more Spanish
what'd you think of ed Bassmaster that
food's all right bro ain't heard in 67
followers he's my friend and that I
influence in the movie bro yeah and who
put that movie together exact Polly sure
help cast people oh sure - Polly sure
man that forgot me in the movie brother
you had to audition I was gonna get a
longer role but I couldn't commit to it
because we had to do that short in
Riverside I didn't do another show on
Saturday and how was it working with
Billy Zanesville easy bro never went
from fist bumping me to 15 me but taking
my hat Titanic style
yeah bro all reminiscing on his movie by
whether I talk to him bro I put in touch
with the wrap party bro hey my favorite
scene in that movie ever ever ever was
in a movie Posse bro they have that
black Cowboys Mario Van Peebles and the
American 90s and a bunch of other fools
right and and that dude I used to be in
the real world or a different world with
Bill Cosby
they [ __ ] head up but anyways
Billy's dating a cowboy like a
Confederate and is that like a cup of
car a cup because man you know all
Richard over there behind that 19 he's
part of the moat ISA tribe and they're
like I drew from the motifs of pride
from yeah and he clicks on the copper
you got more Tisa Oh Sam like that yeah
the Galleria yeah that's how you guys
met first time always yeah bro I
remember remember can
by their by their favorite jokes my
favorite joke you had a big family
because I have a big family seven kids
of my family uh-huh we were all old toys
I remember you were rotted the age of
our had a joke that said that we were so
poor we will go to our neighbor's house
and wear their clothes ago has them the
rot you were Ronnie that was Rodney I
had you had a funny one any German a
finest Griffith is his professional name
Griffin was his the Griffin there's a
Toni Griffin yeah who was Merv Griffin's
and I had to get permission and he
wouldn't give it to me cuz they hey I
might get a sitcom are you serious Wow
and people are greedy even before this
[ __ ] takes up I was everything you know
and the man to see you know yeah so
that's the little inside somebody's a
Griffin from family game do our job
without back in the day without you know
man
we were so poor man well tell my mom and
dad butters only award walkie talkie yes
and I hold it one happy like it hey it's
me Anthony where you at
all right here right to my brother
yeah
what's up fools up even evening at the
improv boy yes yes and [ __ ] down
Comedy Central Pepsi yes lick back and
on the show also was George George Lopez
yeah I did know who I didn't know men
Sam yeah and I'm so up it was also ain't
neither cover down the road was Jeb bald
ass way Jeff had something on Annie back
here company on the road can he produce
was another guy and he had column is he
on the show and then he went to comedy
compadres and [ __ ] no no no it was are
[ __ ] dumb channel 5 KTLA
KTLA every Thursday at 10:00 okay and
then they'll put yeah I remember they
would put the reruns right before
culture class or something right I don't
know whether he catch on and then he got
to give Joe a popular Jeff out there's
Paul Rodriguez then eagle on did comedy
because they know comedy local slam and
it was too close to Def Jam and even
poetry will come on and then I guess
Latino comedian are not really known to
be vulgar not Def Jam do tell me they
were telecommunicators take a couple of
bucks give me a couple of [ __ ] joke
please they wanted to be robbed nobody
getting wrong I couldn't I couldn't I
couldn't get on Depp shut up
because you weren't wrong right Wow and
they would say come on come on we got
word Hutchison so they always say hey
man I love you I said That's not me man
cuz they died was warm and also you did
The Tonight Show with Johnny Carson
originally is
right yeah [ __ ] it down no but after
the first show he said in the parking
lot I like you I'm gonna bring you back
so but even before my manager he said I
like you work on stuff I'm bringing back
his magic t1s while you're taping
something speaking of that show I
believe that night like pack you know
then three in the morning come on how
many though so that we tape that many
years ago and those joy Medina said he
was doing the old talk robin beard and
another show that was la was a comic
strip live I love that show yes just
that started at the factory right Wow
the host was a man will something the
host was a guy at the convenient to know
well Shriner that was right about close
enough we could just say but that's what
man laughs actor what it was really it
was just say hold on whoa Wow buddy Fox
comedy there wagon help Dorothy furthers
men with hot to of the reality yeah and
you have him with the host but that's so
popular bro really dude it was popular
bad you know I have no I watched yeah
yeah been a you know thirty mornings yep
then Jamie Masada didn't have no
scholarship live and there was just
comedy on Keller whether at midnight and
they will show other comedians on live
on a radio they had a different setup on
comic strip live didn't they like the
bar was not back where where it is now
yeah super forward Long Beach that would
be to be a language comedy club right
now our only own perform there
ice house with Allah have factory never
dies house hello always the ice house
Jordan Brock right first time I would
hurry no yes yes you are driving a trap
[Laughter]
ricochet photo what's that joy with
dinner I said that he was a yeah like
when we first met he was crazy
Hollywood we first wrote about the dude
that will say that he was gonna get on a
tram jump pave a path that I played out
everywhere dog yeah we're gonna put it
everywhere little people with beach
cruisers new people's office pop it off
heard on Simpson's office from New York
and half fill up and then that person
was telling at or like why
what everybody want man leave Beecher's
whatever it was that writer and well the
way we see Hollywood here could we live
here but everybody about a telling it
that you've made it when when it used to
be when when Compton was huge when rap
but gangster rap yeah use my family's
the cargo every time you can't a man can
we go to Compton and I would go wait
wait we got Compton in Chicago we get
project I got shootings in Chicago but
they wanted to go Compton and really
hide back there I mean yeah Straight
Outta Compton came out yeah 88 yeah jump
out of the car to get busy Echo Park
[Laughter]
Compton the favor my brother came here
with his wife and they wanted to see the
Hollywood Walk of Fame and stuff alright
so I took him over there and they're
just like Michael Jackson star even my
uncle when he came he was like what
facet when I we had a limo for him to
see Beverly Hills but he he went past
some fat burger and the liquor store was
like upset so he we cancelled Beverly
Hills and just always burger and liquor
store he was happy that that was his la
moment
are they all from Chicago they're from
the south you're from Chicago right yeah
South Side so you were a group in the
project I started yeah what projects
they're not there anymore like I know
they have like green green yeah like
Robert Taylor homes out there right and
they're all going down Wow
those expensive condos they that was the
word so all of that is now College and
rich people yeah everybody with a sober
two rows model you're right right yeah
they further to the suburbs and then
they stopped buses stopping at a certain
time so you can't get back oh that sucks
man they started doing that what was
that well they prevent you from getting
back to the neighborhood after a certain
hour it's like a way to force poor
people to get out yeah out of wherever
they don't want you to because the white
suburbs the white people in suburbs said
hey we're tired of being the suburbs we
want to go into the city live in the
city play in the city live at the lake
so they said okay so they switched him
yeah now all the all the people and the
projects on the suburbs but the King get
back in because that's what's happening
now with the cities because we were
talking about Detroit and Detroit's
right wanting to they they wanted to
basically like get rid of the city of
Detroit and just have the suburbs kind
of come in and swallow the city and just
become all just a neighborhood basically
not have any suburbia but just this have
like a park area instead of what was the
major downtown area I'm a truant that
was like what the idea was but then a
lot of young people are coming in they
want to live in these cities and they
want to live in the like downtown LA
became the same way downtown LA was
nothing until like hipsters were
starting to come in and wanted to live
in an apartment in the city and then
that was the thing and it wasn't about
going to the suburbs anymore and buying
Chicago's very much like that -
performing at the Charlotte common zone
yeah and the whole area is like calm
like you know it's be [ __ ] they were
just telling me that people that worked
or it's I'm not man right there by hotel
room with prostitutes father - it's
around the cemetery here was all crack
but another having a brand new condos
their bikes you could buy your current
trend every [ __ ] season every other
little shopping center all their trippy
man Oh cookie cutter yep yep you can
walk here at night oh sure we went to
Charlotte man and we saw the Confederate
Monument there for the regular Cemetery
for everybody else and then they had a
cemetery just for the Confederates but
you can read their names the raw face
seen something facing dog the monument
to get you salute and there was one
person we found an actual slave in that
Charlotte we get new because everyone
had a date they were born this guy was
that around 75
well guesstimate yeah I don't know but
they don't know how to beat one like you
like he had a big war and they said he
was a slave to gent to loyal servant yes
yeah he had cared for him and [ __ ]
plots there for like people that from
[ __ ] 1901 and to 1970 man [ __ ] that
man me ma'am burn me bro should all be
in Venice Beach I have a few uncles and
nephews who searches I mean Hanson I'm
sorry your last name - in Charlotte you
know yeah Griffin and Griffith where
Griffith is a
methyl methyl I'll be flight and Griffin
somebody's been on drugs
I used to be a little game I know he'll
call Griffith but it was like a flying
thing and he shot arrows with a dude on
top I want to stay there because the
devil used to have a video game Griffin
no those were ostriches they were flying
though the buter Griffith and I always
got confused with Eddie Griffin yeah
because when you say that because I were
confused you with our other comedian
who's real clean too
and every confused him was the other
comedian who's not so clean who passed
away and the other same name what does a
little baby he's a little baby special
like oh you do a sweater like this and
they talk like that they put a little
hat and then he'll put a big old glass
there to be his grandfather huh he died
no he's alive Oh who's the one who died
I think he looked like this other guy
who passed remind me of this other guy
who passed away wait so you Robin Harris
is not was not going yeah he's saying
you remind him okay row who's clean okay
and still here
yeah yeah and he does cruise ships yes
yes Farley yes here he is he did
character there's a little boy yes he
did a mom and he'll put on his glasses
and meet his grandfather
Bebe's kids yeah no Ralphs Harris hi
Ralph yes yes he was at the Laugh
Factory last week I want we're coming up
or you see in common then you grew up
with you know you known you but you're
so tired you remember their names I saw
him it was funny guy you do he walked
away so bad when I get bored in a plane
Anthony you turn on my phone yeah let's
are looking at people call you know
Soleri that they're not right so I say
all this guy I don't know just kind of
thing is here over here we have [ __ ]
of santan John Leguizamo whatever manic
woman over here so whatever so [ __ ]
this Duke comes in there man holding it
like a horn section bag and curly ass
for her and I say yogi and every cold
myself says yummy said it out loud to
hear it was ktg but he was but I had
enough miles saved up yeah she's out say
your first class yeah he was it right
and he was the last for that [ __ ]
played mm-hmm Patel thinking you know
what before we got on the plane they
wanted three volunteers so are things
about the day was they said that um if
they lied to us and told us the pain was
too full we need three volunteers but
all they were trying to do is get Kenny
G they want to give you walking around
back in for like a maniac trying to [ __ ]
you'll find a play for that saxophone or
clarinet whatever it is the soprano sex
it's a sex offender
I'm so glad I didn't go Edward all
Yankovic
oh yeah Greg for the keep go - your
video so how bad is Kenny G doing they
can get on a plane bro it must have been
a last-minute thing
it just surprised me missus oh they
won't kick anyone else wanna play know
what I was late for playing and I ran
and the plane was leaving pilot saw me
came back in everybody on the flight was
pissed off you know why right because he
came back and I walked in and that's pre
9/11 that was free now so you started at
a comedy cottage and then Zanies like
those are your Chicago yeah but but but
in Chicago you had a lot of one-niners a
lot of on the right you had Wisconsin on
the left you head was constant on the
right you had Indiana so you could work
constantly to find out your crowd find
out your style you know like that
another to you to find your style what
you wanted to do you know or the crowd
meet outside you you know it was
interesting because you had the comedy
club in the white area you had the black
lounges and what the brothers were so
you know if when I went to the brothers
they were going man you corny I don't
even like what you say bright you save
it because you're corny plus feet up
they smoking they drinkin they picking
up women all that it was new to me I was
like oh gee Papa
I love overtime man I've already bought
my clue that Sears bro or JCPenney I've
never been outside of a store called
target JCPenney or whatever my mountain
sergeant Howie I wouldn't you on your
underwear and socks and your honor
so here I am you know gene pompa right
yeah he's looking for shorts widget
installed for shorts bro
since we finally go to Abercrombie &
Fitch and he gets shorts there you know
I like these clothes so I put a bunch of
stuff brought hoodie a shirt jeans
I walked outta there was a bunch of
stuff so I'm doing a performance show
same act by the way right same cadence
emeriti this fat ass lady like this fat
lady was party forty-four at the time I
was 28 she goes why should it be why we
love clothes what should I be a surfer
whether we're at that what is that I put
her was uh she's a bad dog yeah yeah
don't hold back and keep going and get
off right there on Canoga Canoga Avenue
and they walk around with everyone
else's dress I mean it's what I learned
when I moved to New York because I moved
from Ohio to New York Dayton Ohio it's
another small suburban that's a country
self-exam Xenia yeah and it's not the
countryside but it's a smaller town than
like LA or New York but when I moved to
New York I was hoping for diversity
people who have had a better who are
just you know more more accepting and
worldly know you can be a racist or a
hillbilly mentality even living in LA
New York
yo Chicago I've seen it fair very not
cut you off Martin Luther King active
being you know stone
of all the places I've been to and I've
been down south Chicago is the most
racist place because Chicago's very
segregated in the way it's built and
drawn and governed is always been that
way it's forced it to be that thing they
were on a messiness goki before Mexicans
there weren't Mexicans and Puerto Ricans
and it was just like then they have
their own area separate from Pilsen
yeah Pilsen for the Mexicans right they
pretty much stay there so you knew you
knew exactly in Chicago if you wanted to
go well it was Italians you went
somewhere yes against somewhere gay if
you were coming our boys tell you were
coming out yeah so Chicago is very
segregated and that's it yeah oh yeah oh
yeah like seven and how was it when
you're doing standing back then I mean
cuz you go back in the days like I mean
there was Steve Harvey there's like
Robin Harris I don't know if he was
doing comedy back then got Bernie Mac
all those people like you know young
lady right Bernie Mac I read with Bernie
he was a Bernie bro
[Music]
my brother my brother brother he corny
[ __ ] and whites didn't get him
white oak who they did not get Bernie
well I don't understand who I don't I
can't understand him who but blacks
loved him and we were always close
whenever he would come back to LA he was
they call me Tony how's your sag card
I'm gonna give casting directors gonna
call you in about five minutes
sure enough so he was always Chicago
through and through he never forgot
about it we were in a Bernie Mac show
yeah yeah
yeah you did a lot of TV and and movie
work and you know who else did stuff
like that throwing in friends
remembering how important it is to like
keep that health insurance going and all
that stuff and keeping your sag up to
date that's I mean that's so cool that
he looked out for you there Rodney
Dangerfield did the same thing and he
would put his friends in movies and
stuff and I think I'm apologia told me
that his last movie the one before he
died the one with my ex-wives whatever
the last one was everybody was that I'm
moving an important week everybody
health insurance yeah
hopefully the would do well everybody
get a check of the year feel like Adam
Sandler kind of does that to of his
friends you know Chris Rock David rich
Tom dreesen also dude Reese's Chicago oh
yeah Southside Porter or someone I think
in New York ah Southside Chicago
he pretty much owns that that one over
there and he's a partner in that Wow
he was one of those Boosler to perform
again when they brought everybody back
and when they started paying everybody
back well when it started paying
everybody like before everybody
performing and not getting paid but
everybody was performing by the way but
one is not a pain they started kicking
the riffraff out and then literally
paint and then like Elaine Boosler Tom
dreesen and then that one who committed
suicide were banned for life my neighbor
he was a good friend who wasn't named I
was along here it's just the guy who did
it right after its Tonight Show said no
no that's
oh that's the same in real life okay but
they were writing about the same guy
yeah okay Latino mm-hmm no do it what
New York he was he was friends with Tom
that could mean to have real long hair
he's framing Larry David oh [ __ ] um
Richard Lewis Richard Lewis comes at the
end of the book he said that but after
that they know the boogie say that after
my friend committed suicide I went on a
25-year drug and drinking binge Richard
Lewis Richard Lewis yeah probably good
Wow
yeah his friend passed away his friend
the one who committed suicide him and
Richard Mootoo I later gather and when
I'm that guy was like not a bad read but
you know what I mean your first uh
career in comedy and you meet somebody
it takes one of the wing that yeah
Richard his wing but Richard became more
successful was that whoo - yo near wing
you know who I always liked who was real
cool on the road was Shirley Hemphill
yeah fair funny fair front and she would
always you know you had lunch paid for
you to lunch
yeah so she was cool she's part of that
yeah sure she was another she was on the
best of Def Jam team but they were
busted out after sex with me yes I think
it was the best of the best
everybody on that thing and it's [ __ ]
rich or famous where huntresses on a
Chris Tucker
Martin Lawrence's hosting and that
getting goes down watch out now
Jan 3 bring Anthony Brown and um
and I'm sure Underwood showing it with
fun yeah verify onyx in the money yeah
chef that joke about man she's - you
have a good man you gotta hide them off
best Fritz having about mo jump over my
shoe a [ __ ] over a yard
yeah sure very funny and again if you're
from Chicago
very nice what does she mean when I'm at
the end her show back then yeah she will
say shout out to my man in blue or
she'll a police officer or to my guys in
blue or something like that
I don't know [ __ ] I got a police officer
and she in the army or support of
eternity I'm not I'm not she is in the
fraternity then she probably related to
them yeah yeah what's up boo
when we first the last time I saw you
why we see you but you were at the
Montreal Comedy Festival I never get but
there's a ya know yeah you know it's a
shame bro because like when I saw a
recent I'm sorry said Montreal and they
had a Royals junior and they had another
another guy there was an urban act more
like Def Jam kind of act I think I
forgot his name man but there was these
two people valid you'll never see when
this thing showed I don't want to put
him in this thing so Roy was in that guy
go now this guy's too dirty this gets to
cleave but pretty much were they were in
the same show I forgot it they were
probably Rick Rick hair up got name but
he wasn't much we all for the first time
or earthquake first place first time
about to Rio
after all these years yeah movie special
yeah tours yeah million dollars and he
finally goes to and also Lunia was there
luenell Tiffany and a bunch of other
black females were hanging down in
Montreal and I would I say man it was
about [ __ ] time I felt when Melanie
Camacho did your show you know had never
been to the Ice House in all her years a
comedy crazy I said I couldn't leave
that because because you have a lot of
gatekeepers
yeah and if they don't like you yeah you
don't get in as we were little like you
man there was evil of bet loop in Kenya
what's up booze I thought it was gonna
be so you have a book yes behind little
after because so many people think
the life of a comic is just always funny
he's in the hot ideas it remember the
heart some admirable put go go to the
room eat a [ __ ] sad will put the
[ __ ] head down like I mean not to
like but to put into a dark side but I
was paid like [ __ ] shut up would kill
myself or [ __ ] the 12 hours to show you
now said we I don't know she's saying I
understand a lot communion before the
show that you go river rafting or
fishing with the owner or a helicopter
ride what the fall for to break your
ankle himself or the show well like you
say it like a guy who was going to show
cat from Chicago LA Authority you guys
were talking about the road and he'll I
know with me I had to learn politics of
the road I had to learn the politics of
hanging out with the headliner so you
can get more work and all that stuff
losers talking about that last week it's
well yeah Mike Young yeah it's a handful
of unwritten rules he kind of like learn
yourself alright know as I go cuz I I
don't I don't drink I don't smoke and I
was married so what do you do he prays
so being loose right I was just like and
then they would just go your convention
began you know there was in Chicago they
were since paying comics by money drugs
you know hats yes or whatever something
even women do let me not for me but what
happens you know that there's still a
woman over there robbed us you know a
lot of comics would you know
we have the condo and lotta young comics
would come more women I was and I would
say dude this is our sanctuary if you
bring in somebody bring me one but I
would say look I don't know if that girl
has a boyfriend
or she just has somebody who's gone cuz
everybody knew where we live she might
little door open right right
everybody knew we got paid on Sundays
Yeah right it's set up right there right
so I would just say dude don't bring
anybody here this is our sanctuary this
were weekend they stole Victor loves
eyes for reals ah oh yeah you're looking
out for yourself dear man speaking of
that like we're at the over to Orlando
look at Tampa improv and then we're all
hey now you know we were smoking weed
and then somebody came knocking we
didn't fight no one to the green roots
with a condom right oh well you get was
tapping to get it with a bottle tapping
the door right just acquire that fool
left wait a three-minute started
laughing bro how do you like you
probably at the show but you knew that
with a condom what I have right
everybody know I did that right [ __ ]
up a Mac comes out I was bad welcome how
about myself myself myself in the condo
and man I was part of all we I don't
know
I don't know how many people I gave the
cold to the [ __ ] cops when I left
they stole everything they stole the
television how'd they take the TV when I
was bolted to the wall they stole
lighters well you know what I did the
improv and doubtless and the place they
put me out there was no TV and I was
like hey man stone T oh you know the
crack dealers you know I was like so
because whenever that happened
my mom always over slide up the dressage
or to the wall to the door so nobody
could get in and so I I did that with a
lot of condos because the cuz the club
owner doesn't care what happens to you
you don't care about curtains right yes
yes I know man and I said man you used
to chicken in in the last headliner
still there yes yes talking about I have
a short ways it was still I never got to
perform it I mean one after the first
time because I would I had one time and
I said young you need we need more and I
told the assistant who was the lady I
said look I know you do
you have more than one town because
you're a woman and I'm sure and my wife
has know I'm going to get some towels
and you all are gonna pay and I never
got to work there again because I was I
was using my authority well though was
this this was a funny bone in Ohio
laughs I think yeah sorry laugh comedy
cafe in Tucson with a manager and a
waitress used to
anaconda - oh my god wow that is that is
you know wake up I see them
well I wouldn't work together so you met
your wife in while you were starting
comedy in Chicago right yeah
and you worked for well she was your
boss right
she thought I was I was lazy she hated
me
because she thought cuz I did cuz I I
was going to college I was working and I
was doing stand-up so I was tant tired
when I got home I mean got to work at
seven thirty eight and she's yeah you
filthy well you probably yeah yeah your
party yeah she thought was Marty chasing
skirts yeah you know we've just two
different people I'm trying to make it
[Laughter]
wouldn't you start head lightning spots
it was a while it was a while I think
we're not for the ecology at neck all
that all that stuff man
NACA like that the words bro I remember
I was at the NACA brought to discover
standing and Josh Woolworth next to me
and he rarely slips had to give him mine
he ran out a booking slip is that a
rover and that's a given mind this rule
[Laughter]
will the poster with me there and
everything broke but those commies are
male trying to get guest spots by trying
like get a fallen that's even more
desperate no poster yeah no nothing
you're hanging out with Bobby holiday
you know every developers but you know I
like 150 colleges because I worked with
a group called make me laughed it was
the TV show and we had we had noon noon
shows and yeah
I hate those man so you leave soda gets
it opens it and go back and sit there
all right wanna let you the pizza a
busier release here the blender
I did one one time you Berkeley bra I
heard it with the dollars no room
nothing we just drove and we got there
wouldn't even know we're gonna stay he
didn't know either
there was no microphones a little lapel
but the next year I wrote my next year
Gabriel NCOs and Ernie G went and then
that guy told him you know same simple
motor student again no rooms but for the
next year show so it is we're gonna stay
well the last community hooked up bro
ending I ended up sleeping somebody's
house maybe you guys could go to the
after-party no bro didn't get nothing
wrong yeah some guy hooked him up and um
they sit in the back of somebody's truck
by the outsider house and like the guy
gave a piece of boxes yeah so so you
don't being that my wife is a
psychologist she she looks back and goes
all the comics that was you all were
abused did you know we're trying to just
get ahead but she said in the real world
that's not allowed
[Laughter]
so true though but because we don't have
a union because we know if I don't do it
a comic behind ya every Peters will be
there always ruins any sort of movement
Phil Salman he'll do it yeah or they'll
put a pool table in there and no you got
their headlining you know it's tough out
there bro because okay so you're gonna
go out there headlining now this club
owner has to convince the morning radio
show and morning TV and but they don't
have to convey have to lie to them and
say for the cabbie on the radio show you
know what
even in my level they'll say no don't
say something like oh man we have a
shooter I would echo that you bro you're
nobody
and and you know what you know you're
gonna have to go to that [ __ ] mall
and pass off fly really owner yeah and
yeah you don't want to do that but you
know I thought you do it the comedy on
the ground in Reno you know you're gonna
do because you're you you're gonna sleep
at the owner's house you're gonna get up
in the morning go to press with him you
know do all his chores free tickets all
day yes that's the worst it sucks just
go fishing with him little different
like he says like comedy and it can I
hanging out of the headliner for lunch
to get more gigs sometimes like you're
at a level where you're gonna go hunting
with the owner to get more gear - yeah
and like when I asked what's the name
Alka now yeah
give them Elka no let you know
comedians keep coming back cuz that's
hunger out there and if I can't give you
$100 they would do it for 5 because they
goes they keep coming back for less yeah
and it's like oh my god do you yeah it
is the cheapening of a trade oh yeah and
then you know are those guys that are
doing that they're willing to do
anything to headline whether it's steal
someone material no new baby works just
doing she has been done before this
Colorado Springs bottom of the barrel
right and you see it and the right
people are dumb but people know what
they're going into whether they're gonna
go to a special event or just another
night I go there for their wings to
premiere do karaoke right after the show
one dollar paps because like you say
you're trying to be professional and
it's like you're dealing with like
sleazy car sells yes yeah yeah you know
sometimes it could be disguised as nice
people but they're not know you know
it's very few club owners that are
really nice like the comedy magic club
yeah real nice guy
I wouldn't take him to Wrestlemania if
you go there if you're with a friend if
they say hey you you want something to
eat versus other clubs will go no drink
ticket one drink - she's thirsty - right
where's her drink ticket I thought it
was a this is not happening Comedy
Central video when you're talking about
your daughter I'm yeah
preparing for your night the Tonight
Show and all that hair that was going
there going through our like goddamn it
brought me to tears man six weeks six
weeks yeah how did you write the whole
bit word why were yourself or just
ordered to improvise in one night and
just know it was at the
the comedy acts comedy art festival
Aspen in me in the mall as a
storytelling service and it was and they
simply was up there they were new and
they just say hey to the comics tell us
the story
and my daughter spoke to me and said
tell my sir because I haven't talked I
never told anybody that I I lost the
daughter yeah I just keep it to myself
but that night my daughter said tell my
story and I told that him and after five
minutes there the narrator just said
okay tell live don't you know so all
that I felt that was the first time
after Toby about all that emotion yeah
because it's funny cuz a lot of
comedians can [ __ ] about like ah you
know I got to go out here I gotta go
work the road you never did a real job
or something like that and you have a
lot of stuff in your head maybe your mom
called yeah your lady yo but I mean this
goes beyond that like deeper into like
the darkest pit of the universe of human
life and I was just like wow and then
when you broke into that uh gotta be
like Denzel Washington in a training day
and buck your ass up and I was like wow
cuz it was out of your character but I
was I do this came from the [ __ ]
heart you know a lot of guts Bill burr
was also telling the story he has a
story of you know growing Irish you know
everything's hardcore and and if he
cried his father made fun of him and I
thought that that was very moving
because for Irish God to say you know I
was crying and my father he bought me a
doll to make fun of me all that stuff he
was like people I think a lot of comics
although they're not all honest with
themselves and honest onstage like that
but a lot of cop maybe later in their
years they do get like that but a lot of
comics hold that stuff in but those guys
a lot of times where they grew up
as the more sensitive kid maybe they
didn't even realize it you know you were
the more sensitive kid of your family
but you came from you know very macho
sort of dad but you know there are
remembered your memory did he rip up
your Thanksgiving that your Thanksgiving
that like something you created you know
and it was heartbreaking for you
it becomes podcast fodder and everybody
laughs at it but anyway well gobble I
think that's why comics are great
dramatic actors because they have they
can do back that range
my life Joe for the crib all right yeah
so let's back up for a second cuz you
just jumped into his daughter passing
away but you you and your wife got
married and had you had a daughter yes
and and she was diagnosed with Down
syndrome first that was the first kind
of surprise in your lives together yeah
but it was cool because um when I told
my mom my mom was cool she said okay
tell me what the doctor said
say well she started she she she was
born 75 pounds
and my mom Paulson said were you born
five pounds
yeah but the doctor said you know she's
premature and my mom said you premature
and I said yeah but the doctor said
where she will be slow and my mom paused
and said you didn't walk for fourteen
months just take their daughter home
love her and let's see what happens and
now and you know I took off to the click
comedy clubs they weights that for
watcher while I was on stage and so it
was cool and um and she could beat me
cuz she she wasn't walking but she could
crawl quicker than I will walk to the
door yeah so it was cool and I didn't
know who to rent gage her by because it
was the only child so yeah and then and
then so the the bigger tragedy of course
was it happened a couple years later
then yeah and she she was diagnosed with
leukemia yes my son's father remarried
and I remarried and his two-year-old
daughter she had cancer pretty much the
last year of her life and she died it to
two years old yeah yeah reality show
about a situation except she didn't have
but it doesn't matter
cancers I guess she's just more
susceptible your daughter because of the
down syndrome that makes her more
susceptible to certain health problems
right yeah and and then you know I was
on the road and my wife said you know
she's sleeping a lot more so we should
go to the hospital so as soon as I got
home with him right to the hospital to
Children's Hospital and they said how
long has she been Orange she needs blood
right now
so so we gave her blood but she went to
a cardiac arrest so and she's - so she's
fighting people when they're trying to
stick her and she's not screaming and so
we had to put her in a comatose using
that for like three months
and I still had to go on the road to pay
bills and so yeah that's tough like
that's we've seen comics you know like
you were saying there's always there's
something in your head you know when
you're performing and like Marcela she
performed the night that her dad died
you know like that was drove from Edessa
de la she's got a gig for the last three
years
yeah yeah and and then you know you went
to work back on the road a week after
your daughter died right how do you pull
it out of you and I mean are you faking
it on stage or does your comedy take a
hit you did say your comedy started
becoming more dark yeah cuz confess it's
a night show they want like Jimmy Jim
Jimmy Fallon everything's clean yeah
just goofy just happy right
and I relief was not in the head space
for that and and the child and
coordinators say hey you know you need
to pull it back you need to smile more
and our sister cuz I didn't tell anybody
- what I was good cuz I would do this
show tonight's show I would rush to the
Children's Hospital because my wife and
my daughter
yeah that's tough
yeah how long you do that for for a
while yeah it was for these second and a
third time I was on tonight's show so
she would see me she watches Tonight
Show with me so she was confused cuz I
was there yeah and she would hear me on
TV hey yeah so it's cool but yeah and
then afterwards it was like hey you
through the show after she passed you
just tried to do the earth show and you
know you just threw your show yeah you
did it you think that is easy it's
harder for a comedian to do his job
that way it is harder than to be going
through all that stuff and still trying
to be funny must be really [ __ ] tough
I'm pretty sure your plumber man you can
pull em away right yeah yeah I mean is
are you unlike on autopilot doing your
act like without any mentioning the
daughter yeah
and how have your act changed since then
yeah because since then I've um I've
developed I mean not develop but I have
multiple sclerosis which is and I came
after your daughter because they say a
mess comes out of trauma your body does
something that it changed in the in your
immune system fights itself not to you
some yeah my members jeha yeah but you
still I mean so ms compared to a child's
a peasant if anything that has
everything is with that's it
I got a cold I lose my house I lose my
car that's it
okay peers in comparison [ __ ] man
Michael Jordan [ __ ] playing with a
fluid score in eighty if I put a [ __ ] to
compare with after the way through bro
yeah God every night broke gotta be
funny go back to that comedy condo work
what that could be like like nas to Mike
yeah
so how so did you guys find yourselves
as far as after your daughter's gone
right you have a different relationship
now right I'm sure impacted your
marriage well we definitely you usually
what couples it either broke you up spit
you up because you won't think about it
because when I see her I'm thinking
enough so you Trish try to create a
whole life or it just make you much
stronger you what do you say that about
what you know like that lets you compare
to your daughter but when I had a baby
mom my man and my son had a flu I look
at him and we alas array bro you were
screaming
[Laughter]
[Music]
relations relationship skills give me
much to look forward to I'm not walking
away just really giving up yeah like
just like stopping no cuz the pain could
be crushing I mean ability yes for my
wife good I didn't know until I read the
book I mean you wrote the book that she
had contemplated suicide yeah right
because the book the way the book is
structured it's back and forth your
story your side of the story and her
side of the story in each chapter right
like so I always read her stuff to find
out about her no there's lot of stuff I
didn't know it's funny how when I'm like
I know in your book that in the black
community and even knows I know the
Latino community you're not allowed to
be a nerdy without thinking people
you're white yeah yes and there's no
nerds
there's no mexican nerds bro where you
call [ __ ] nerd it's always like I'm
sure me white why I don't like Carla
ball lowriders just because you spoke
differently but you know because because
in the black world for comedy everybody
want to be Redd Foxx for Richard Pryor
yeah Eddie Murphy Redd Foxx so you just
want to do impressions
that's not baby the man many voices
weird kids yeah keep them over in the
like like how about Boris growing up and
doing his comedy and in Antony's age
would have been he white
he thought he white he's doing the what
he said intellectual comedy to make us
think right and that's what some
brothers who say to me you know if they
have been high you know you tried that
you try and do all that intellectual so
I just tried to just be funny
I'm Billy silly I want to do impressions
of Michael Jackson John Wayne and they
were just have you look at any any
picture it
there's no nerds brother or Latino bro
because if you're a nerd you're wider
you're gay
so what in your so what helped you guys
in your relationship like or it was it
just natural because of your love being
strong already what helped you guys know
it's you know did you turn on each other
at different times
no it just kind of held it in we would
like some zombies you know could you you
can see through a lot of stuff just by
remote reflex you know I really think
you know I really didn't hear the birds
or the singing or the smell of roses
because we were just just going through
life it's not really not enjoying my
stepmoms been 2 years now yeah my son
stepmom and we all get along we're all
cool but she spent a whole year and a
half in the hospital with her daughter
day 24 hours I thought was so kind of
sad you know that that little grow up
all her friends were Hospital people
yeah yeah she do have friends outside
that was very sad yeah I mean my son
dwells on it he's 14 and he dwells on
certain things like she didn't never got
to go to school and make friends she
never got to do this
well that was reset that was one reason
that
my wife get into the field she did
because while we were in a hospital life
it was certain kids that their parents
were never there because their parents
had to work so they would just be going
through there's this stuff all by
themselves so that in your book the book
II wrote that book you can find it yeah
you can physical copy so we can show it
titled behind the laughter yes I'm good
at Amazon right yeah it's on Kindle or
aught audio - right did you record a
version you did it cool and then bridge
did it - you guys both what's up with
all these right behind the left and
that's out now right right yes came out
today or yesterday yesterday oh wow yeah
comedians tale of tragedy you know it's
an audible yet it is who reading it now
not me because she didn't read so I felt
I shouldn't read it but we got to two
actors a man and a woman doing your part
yeah but it's funny because in the
audition they produce the publisher
which is sending us white guys because
it'd be our old white guy going cuz I
would listen I'll go he sounds like oh
my god and then I'll go right right that
way he would talk like that
yeah we need we need some color
you know bring some flavor yes I know
change your your
you're what is it honey East your th to
F get an honorable man for I got credit
747 or one credit or twenty one dollars
and forty two stands man if you don't
have auto I have audible so yeah so was
several platforms nerd I want to be
Houdini dude I want to be a cop
my mom father is old and wallet and she
ripped everything up but left a little
play will you put the bet the idea
big bad just put my name on top that's
cool I think your mom probably why did
you be a cop you know I know
well you know follow the table you know
what to let go could have broken out
with metal right but yeah I wouldn't be
an escape artist cuz you said you won't
be a magician and then when you found
out joining cars I want to be that
communication you feel like right which
one when we had here the comedian Jimmy
super oh yeah so I thought I was on the
right path and I took I would take my
maestro my my straitjacket to show a
show-and-tell at school
it's funny when the mind is not you so
like imagination and letting it go but
you know what it can squash though to if
you're not careful that kid could have
his dreams laughs you don't know but
there's more Howard's birthday bro you
know when Three Stooges who the [ __ ]
cares oh yeah my mom was always cool and
she allowed me cuz cuz it was
lip-syncing before lip-syncing get big
so if I was Michael Jackson my mom was
the Jackson 5 if I was James Brown
my mom was but then a teenager I had a
straitjacket and I was the real
straitjacket it was a real one somebody
stole it on the bus you crazy
straight track someone that needs it
like me
but then use that you asked her to stuff
that for another one right yeah and he
was right yeah he was
no that's created I wouldn't know what
to get myself straight jacked my insane
she called and said hey my son wants to
straitjacket this has to be true because
who calls the insane asylum
except sign you up to different things
that were not for the hood you know yeah
I love that story you said about the Boy
Scouts good man yes we live in the
projects
yeah we had a Boy Scout we have one
meeting and that means the first meeting
half of the people there the boys got
got kicked out like half righty dicks
I hate fired and then and then I'm are
funny because our our [ __ ] it a boy
scout master with a guy from out of
Salvador and every time we talk to turn
it to stop it voice barolay boss they
enforce right it keeps name force
[ __ ] yeah we're the Boy Scouts or the
voice guys well my arm my Boy Scouts
because everybody except my friend were
were gangbangers so I was like you know
that the the the Scoutmaster was
terrorized hey you guys they took over
the men took over so it was boring I was
the only one who wear our little scarf
yes I was the only one all of them with
just bugs they all have two strikes
oh come on this was not fun
over there trying to be a boy scout at
night and your badges were for fake
stuff all right like you didn't do
anything we have better reasons are
cooking Blanche I'm American badge all
that stuff that we didn't do in yeah
they go camping or nothing huh no
because because hiking last no have nice
things
the Boy Scouts they never went anywhere
man yes and went away and then when they
went camping
my brother snuck in a buzz it went like
you they were supposed to go but he
snuck in the bus way to go over there
but he said yeah fun though he said what
happened yeah he goes man
did the guy cook hotdogs [ __ ] cup noodle
in a pot and boil water and get passed
around I look up and fill it up with
water
ghetto Scouts right so I would always
hear about white Boy Scouting they're
doing this and they're like oh man
that's cool but over there dressed like
Teddy Roosevelt like look at the project
look at they teach karate no worth it
we're karate so every tournament was
sweat shorts either black brown eyes
that he was using that bout to hold up
his past like bloodsport huh I have a
friend that why God he went to college
he said the brothers that went to Cal
took up fencing and they were in their
sweats like the mesh all right coming up
No
[Laughter]
but you're pushing your book it's
optional yes yes that's laughs factory
that Factory yeah you show up with my
factory light in Hollywood my first time
I performed there he told me to come
back next week and perform again but I
told him about Jamie I have a TV show I
gotta say about TV set
you know why come back again later so I
never came back and at what time I came
back he goes I don't see you making it
for another seven years and actually
hurt my feelings bro and then I was so
sad I talked to a lot of body man don't
worry about that man what's that he told
me that I should put on shoulder pads
and a football uniform and I should be
the football comic on stage and then I
told Brad was the same story that I was
sad and breadwinner and said that they
should get all the little people he can
find
Jamie's advice catchy little to Brad way
let's get all the little people you can
find and and we'll have a big comedy
show for the little people will call it
the biggest comedy the biggest little
comedy show in Hollywood history so when
I won Last Comic Standing and we had a
jameson on the show I said Jamie Masada
you said they'd take me six or seven
years to make it you're a full of [ __ ]
Matt okay well you know that's why I
never get in the store because Mitzi was
like you know you should do this this
and I was and I was telling her I'm
already commie I'm just trying to get to
San Diego I don't need to change right
yeah but you've already you've already
got material yes I'm just trying to San
Diego I don't have to I don't have to
dress me in purple you don't have to do
this I'm just trying to get to San Diego
Sado sunglasses on in a king right she
took the
Darrell Middleton the military yeah name
- what gruffy Johnson something like
that was like it was something like a
scruffy Johnson my name is Dee right all
right I told her whatever right and then
let's forget performing our week right
take it boring are we can did she call
them back I thought you were changing my
name
you ain't going up at the military yeah
I would call it but see I played games
for her hold it
Ned Horton med holding jokes Ned hold it
Ned Holden yeah he's cooler II know you
are the rule at the knee Griffin your
twitter or instagram people gonna follow
you yes it's a book Twitter mr. laugh a
lot mr. laugh a lot yes
all one word comedian Anthony Griffith
on instagram was so cool thank you for
being a dancing man look you have your
back
I'm glad and I'm glad to see you other
than at the mall right man beer San
Diego the Saturday April 13 this
Saturday Oh this Saturday April 30 of do
you know Spanish or espanol
yeah Holly Tacoma Washington April 18
through 20 bill Tacoma Tacoma comedy
club pending or that club is the green
room there are five drawers each room
has snacks Los Angeles April 26 doing a
set on the cabinet beans April
foolishness it will be beans last day in
LA Albuquerque New Mexico
it's letter Resort April 27th Lincoln
California Thunder Valley Casino I'll
see everybody there for weed California
from
from Eugenia better at managing Portland
Sacramento area see you guys there is
the closest I'll be near Sacramento
because the [ __ ] partial a second
benefit playing games gonna do get
booked over there
how many swirling it aware by a purse be
bellows jokes up may 14th will be back
English and that'll be May 14th
Riverside to live for Center thank you
so much pleasure